[Music]
i can't have men's stuff with anything
but lim i'm sorry one time he told me to
make mensa for chicken i said i'm
absolutely never gonna do that yes why
don't you divorce me
first thing i think about when somebody
says palestinian food is family family
friends eating together
big meals
hearty and heavy
all palestinian dishes are cooked in
large portions for the purposes of
feeding a group of people
we don't have all of the traditional
palestinian cuisine in our menu that was
something we thought about in the
beginning i was like if this is going to
be a palestinian restaurant we've got to
have all the traditional palestinian
food and he said to me you can't just
shock the community in the world with
all of these foods that they've never
heard of you can add some traditional
foods but also add foods that are
regional to the middle east
and i added the top most popular ones
macluba
mensah
and it's all amazing it all tastes great
my name is ayat and this is my husband
my name is abdullahni and we opened the
ayat restaurant together
[Music]
i first met her as an attorney to do
some like contractual work for me and
then i saw her i just put the papers to
the side and i said are you married not
married got to know her yeah we'll never
know if he if he reached out to me for
the contractual purposes or not no it
was actually i remember when we were
engaged
he sat me down like what do you what do
you really want to do in life
at the time i was working in the
district attorney's office i was a
prosecutor
i said well honestly my dream has always
been to open up like an official
catering business just serving
traditional middle eastern palestinian
food
and he said so do it and we kind of just
went head on together i told my husband
i'm like okay i can't start anything
till my mom comes and gives her
blessings and so i tell her ma you have
to come look okay taste this how's it
taste no it needs this it needs that i
needed her to overlook everything
to really know that we can launch it and
every week she'd just come and check in
on things and i would love when she
comes because i'd say hey what do you do
this how do you do this what do you
recommend for this ma i don't know if
this is working
and so it just became like a personal
kitchen for her
[Music]
you're from jerusalem yes from jerusalem
i am in brooklyn 50 years
long time she's interesting when she is
small
like when she's five years she want to
stay in the kitchen and she want to cook
everything that's what inspired me right
because she she had started that
i mean initially it started in the house
yes having nine children you're already
cooking for an army i'm gonna tell you
one thing my life
god
my husband and the kitchen that's where
her source of happiness comes from
feeding people giving them yeah just
that giving not receiving it's not just
about giving it's about making people
gather yes that's that's what that's
what it is for her i tell come come eat
i put it
for everybody come eat
[Music]
now we are at our family farm where
we'll raise our livestock for our
restaurants
every morning i come here first thing i
do is to check on the water they
definitely have enough uh grass to feed
off of for the next three to four weeks
so all the covered ones are all pregnant
and they'll be giving birth in the
spring and the ones that don't have
covers maybe four to five of them those
will be served that i had pretty soon i
don't trust the meat in the market they
don't slaughter it properly they do it
in a very inhumane way and that i'm not
into if i'm going to be in the
restaurant business
my main ingredient is meat
i'll do it right halal is saying in the
name of god the most merciful in arabic
was
and before even slaughtering it you
can't slaughter it in front of other
animals you got to first rest it let it
like sleep like kind of like relax in
peace and then when it relaxes then you
slaughter it and then you wait for the
blood to drain out until the soul fully
comes out and then butcher it
if your butcher has a middle eastern
background you could just tell them i
want cuts of lamb for mensa and he'll
ask you do you want leg or shoulder or
both
alright so i'm just gonna throw the
onions into the pot
for any dish in my opinion that's cooked
with lamb
you need cardamom because it really
helps to reduce the gamey flavor of the
lamb and of course the most important we
have our mensive spice which is grown
from an herb out in the jordanian desert
with the bedouin people and it really
gives the flavor that makes ments of
what it is
we're going to add the yogurt mixture to
the lamb broth the base is the jameed so
jameed is a fermented yogurt the
original form of jameed is in a rock you
have to break it into pieces mix it with
water and have it dissolve until you can
bring it to its liquefied form
the manzip dish originated in the desert
what did they really have right they
were sheep herders so they had to come
up with some kind of dish that was
hearty but at the same time just
consisted of just a few ingredients okay
so this is what some people call sage
bread in arabic it's either called
ishraq or merkuk and the this is a very
thin type of bread it's cooked on top of
a sauce which is a hot plate that's
shaped similar to a dome
and this is very important when making
the men's set because this is the first
layer of the menses that's put on the
bottom of the tray so we break it up
into pieces very informal it doesn't
have to be cut in any specific way
okay i'm going to sprinkle some ground
cardamom on it and now this is my mom's
touch she always likes the top with a
little bit of cinnamon this is the point
in time where we soak the sage bread
with the broth all right so now we're
gonna put the rice
now for the best part now we're gonna
top it with chunks of meat
we're going to top it with the almonds
and finish it off with some parsley
this dish is meant to bring people
together and what the buddha used to do
when there was any conflict between the
different tribes one tribe would
sacrifice a land and that land would be
cooked and made into a mensaev dish and
the two tribes would come together and
in a way break bread together to make
peace so this is a perfect example of a
dish that really brings people together
and unites people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right now we're on 85th and 3rd avenue i
was born and raised in bay barrie went
to all the school local schools here in
bay ridge uh
participated in all the bay ridge events
growing up i mean i know it very well
we've got everybody in bay ridge you'll
find people from all backgrounds in the
middle east yemeni egyptian moroccans
algerians then you have the palestinians
the lebanese and the syrians of course
you have a lot of syrians all right but
it's not just the middle eastern
community you've got the uh the irish
the region you've got the italians
you've got a lot of greeks
and they're just small for the amount of
diversity that it has so it's pretty
cool there's definitely a community here
in bay ridge you know like
people do know each other
especially if you're a business owner
it's good to stay connected with
everybody
[Music]
my goal is to make it a full menu of all
of the traditional palestinian cuisine
that you can find
i want people to be able to come
and say oh my god the last time i had
this was at my grandma's house
or
i only have this back home i've never
seen it here being offered in new york
in a restaurant
i'm cuban in palestinian and he's full
palestinian so this is a really
authentic dish
so only the old school
like the mothers the fathers and the
grandparents know how to make this and
it tastes just like that
you know don't be conservative on the
yogurt
just keep just keep pouring there's mint
stuff being made
there's a gathering with it
[Music]
i think the most we've done in terms of
palestinian culture is just the folk
dancing there's a group called freedom
depka and they do the traditional folk
dance
[Music]
if you went to palestine you will
absolutely see people do the depth gut
you will never go to a palestinian
wedding without seeing the depth that
being done at least twice natural
palestinian music when you're dancing
and it's all upbeat you just naturally
want to get into the depth of rhythm you
want to start jumping you know
a lot of palestinian dances
include
jumps right high activity with the body
so that's that's what the depca is
essentially but it's just in a more
unified form people holding hands going
in a little circle
[Music]
i don't think our intention opening up
the restaurant was to promote awareness
about the palestinian people and the
conflict that they go through but
it's impossible to be or identify as a
palestinian in this day and age without
relating to the conflict palestine
does exist palestine does have a culture
it does have a tradition does have a
cuisine what i want people to see
through
the restaurant palestine cuisine and
culture is that we're full of joy and
welcoming and hospitality and happiness
and we're very family oriented by nature
palestinians in general are very family
oriented my mom was really happy about
it ever since my father passed and then
the kids got older and they all got
married and had their own kids and
got held up with their own lives she
lost a little touch with
that feeling of
being needing to be in the kitchen and
feeding the whole family and and so when
the restaurant opened
that kind of revived in her that spirit
revived in her and and she feels that
things are actually moving living on
through her yeah she's she's smiling
without her there's no exactly
perfect ending done deal
[Music]
[Music]
you